this is just unprecedented it's like
more than we've ever seen and that we
could prepare for Heather Pritchett says
she's run out of food for herself and
for her cats she's one of many people
trapped in Crestline nearly two weeks
after the snow began to come down
people here are still digging out from
the storm and some told us help has been
slow to come if at all the San
Bernardino County Sheriff says there's
so much snow clearing the roads is just
part of the battle we're having tractors
come in and scoop the snow having to
drive it away truck it out and a number
of other things which makes the
operation much slower
[Music]
California more than 75 miles of
Interstate 80 remained closed last night
as plows struggled to put a dent in the
snow-covered Highway some areas got
nearly three feet of snow in just 24
hours